welcome to this video playing bad men
and 46 and is this Iran yep and he is
playing with H for whom okay let's let's
stop this at least them it's a it's a
position where he can be reasonably sure
that it may be never ever occurred on
the board before it would be relatively
normal at the age bonds each bonds are
weak are we at not weaken on g4 is the
normal move then I probably take and
play d5 with them CARICOM type of
position but we can expect the
unexpected here with a guy was playing
age four and move three can't do
anything
okay mmm interesting question should I
play night to before trying to go to the
three this maybe maybe nightie for
something like that but it still looks
tempting
it's difficult for him to control would
be three maybe he can play I'm really
something like 94 94 this is an idea
with the Queen on c1a checking the c5
pawn okay I don't know maybe Bishop
Bishop f5 is also also possible him
maybe the idea being to play Bishop d3
not 93 but Bishop d3 try to establish a
night down
hmm yeah wow this is really weakening a
lot especially deform but maybe there is
some concrete reason for it I really for
his own sake hope for it has some reason
otherwise of white is in very bad shape
okay is this the justification I really
have my doubts about that okay let's
start with taking on b2 and I can take
here and play night to defy this is this
is excellent cannot take on c5 Knight f3
s is too ugly at least I don't think he
he can't afford that
probably needs to move the bishop then I
play b6 we had moved ok b6 can he play
no not really maybe I thought a 3 before
maybe but he can play that it's not yeah
I will take him I absolutely will take
them not just for the pawn but because i
establish now both night cm on before
and deform question is is there some way
that I can um if I've this 95 that's not
not so nice i don't want to allow that i
want to make sure I I keep control him
esox
I don't like a five then when I give up
the d5 square it's not not really great
i can i can simply take care there is no
no big reason not to maybe e5 and e6
this stuff hmm yeah and this wasn't a
good idea I should have prevented that
he goes e 6 this is indeed a bit
worrisome okay I don't mind this is
still excellent i've got two points for
this exchange and the fantastic nights
yeah night f5 also be problematic now
for him if wirings h4 hangs and I can
take each form should I take it maybe he
plays a five then I rather get this
night into the game as well mighty form
slightly ahead on the clock that's good
now it's got this the snide f6 trick so
I better cover this
okay so let's now start to and miss the
pawns yeah I can just take it I think
Queen takes Queen e-form and I've
threatened night f3m check
mmm yeah some way to chat to win it
quickly i don't know maybe queen d3m I
can't a again with my cheese right
resins yeah somewhat somewhat strange
game with starting with age 40 came
around here think like this is
comfortable nothing nothing special
though I don't really know about Quincy
one maybe you know does this all this
already is quite quite nice I mean until
here 93 years also already okay but this
this was in the end it paid off because
he was such a bad move that this is
basically white it's not able to repair
its position after that Joe there are
many good many good continuation this is
this is even better yeah this is even
stronger I didn't see this idea
basically winning winning the house iam
what can resign with a clear conscience
am okay I was only looking at at this
was it with the strategically very nice
position now and they're out here yeah
okay i can i can just take it's okay and
I don't think here I applied it
correctly I shouldn't take be three it
keeps a good position but after a 5 i'm
almost forced to give up the exchange I
don't want to to allow something like
this yeah something like this looks I
don't know I mean it looks it looks weak
and gives the sky some chances to
swindle so I better give them this and
have full control of the position with
the night now controlling the this
crucial squares and right here this this
was was already even stronger I didn't
see that move yeah okay Blackhouse has
total control anyway yeah Knight f6 was
a trick know what you can just drove the
pawns yeah yeah this is losing very
quickly but there really was not more
not much to do Black has control over
the King SAT and I'm just just pushing
pawns and the night simply dominate the
position alright thanks for watching